yeah mate where's the water we're slow
no way we're not we're not falling
you're going up wait don't go up all
right we could do a little little more
like a monster outing around oh yeah try
oh yeah all right monster so just do we
do not want to change jobs then I'll be
captain if you want to run around like
an idiot but I I'm good at engineer now
yeah I'll watch one engineers what you
were yeah engineer it me engineer boy I
feel good about my job I'll be gunner
oh no no no Bob you want to be gunner oh
yeah okay I'll stick with engineer Wade
you're the captain now oh god I don't
know why you are d captain now but here
we go I feel good about this I feel bots
we get of a bot be the engineer now
eight nine bots ten BOTS whoa excellent
no you have to be captain that's that's
the rules
what's happening let's have three BOTS
and see how big how much I bought be
captain no I don't to drive the ship I'm
so bad at driving it's fine man it's all
good you were like go go back wait what
are you doing but now you get to
experience the joy dealing with all
right so we're hunting a monster wayde's
the captain I'm the scary officer and
we're gonna have BOTS doing stuff or
whatever got those ready set video games
so how does this actually work bog yeah
well are you telling the bots to do
stuff yeah I'm trying to make sure that
they know their purpose very damaged
systems what do you mean everything's
working all right systems goddamn
injured we're trying to get to the water
outpost - I see where the swarm is and I
see where the outpost we're trying to
kill the swarm that's our that's our
excuse me yeah we're doing a monster
mission we're hunting my fingers moving
now I thought it was gonna be one
monster not a swarm or hunting the swarm
mark alright how do I load the guns this
is you have to go up and grab ammo from
upstairs and bring it back down guns
loaded
I don't tell if it's loaded top middle
top middle okay so it only has like one
round in it the one goes to that five
the other guns are like machine guns so
they have like a little the green will
slowly go down to show you how those
left are those the ones that replenish
themselves they don't replenish you have
to go up and get more ammo okay
something deep groaning from inside the
crap he's not making me feel better why
is he up here just staring at you Bob
mark I'm gonna get a wrench in a little
screwy so in case you need my help I'm
prepared this is sucky yeah it's freakin
terrible it's the actual worst it's so
bad about it why are you complaining oh
just cuz it's sucky
wait so can I stun baton the bot or us
Gerald Oh Traci Maxwell well we have a
medical officer we've got to all right
we're heading directly to the right now
I got a cave system
Francis look away nothing happened
behind it lip on the radar to the bottom
right bottom right to of the mark yeah
what's up hopefully that was deaf one of
our medical officers Oh what is that
what I don't know you weren't here
you weren't here Bob I had to kill it
for you did you kill something I did
yeah good work dude thanks thanks not
captain wise Francis say things are
getting tense shut the [ __ ] up Francis
look things are getting tense man which
way are we going right now down down I
trying to navigate us through what I
think is cave walls right now we're
going straight down we'll be going back
to the right shortly we're 450 meters
away from the swarm calm down I'm just
saying guys the swarm sounds real bad we
have a very narrow cave or about to go
into so sorry and Brendan Vance actually
you know what I don't know if I can
navigate this cave it may have just
totally Gerald Danko to go charge the
batteries yeah there are any batteries
on this boat I beg to differ
Gerald's a little stupid I think I've
realized this can I just tell him to
follow me
power the power went out so I think we
might be hitting something were you
running the engines too hot oh god what
happened get out it's pressure the
pressure in the engine room Oh what
happened oh god get a suit on get a suit
on that place so I can tell you that god
why am i holding this goddamn guitar fix
leaks hang on I'm going for the engine
to seal a breach what hell happened I
lost power we were right about to hit
something real a bit Oh God yeah yeah
yep we lost two of them no go next how
do you tell where the leak is I don't
understand I don't know I just kind of
dragged my fusion welder along the walls
and I hope for them the thrust is at 95%
Wade what are you doing
I don't know I was dragging that little
arrow around trying now for so long
about keeping the thrust slow if you
don't know that was you I lost power and
then everything with the [ __ ] Oh
power Oh mark there's leaks there's a
leak symbols you see now yeah I see em I
think it's the crew reporting leaks
which they're good little boys and girls
so two of the crew members died oh yes
okay
I didn't like them anyway no Gerald's
the only one that survived
I told thank go to pick some damn leaks
is the ship moving no if it is I don't
know I have no power to the helm I'm
trying to go outside I need to find a
screwdriver again oh we need another
fuel oh we oh we're out of fuel I'm
gonna replace the fuel rod oh god we hit
we have another fuel rod so we should
have we should be back up to power I'm
overheating it I'm overheating it I'm
overheating it I did that thing you said
that was bad to do okay it's okay it's
okay okay I took the other one out and
now we're back below
means shotgun I'm checking for home
roots as I'm doing it I can't there's a
we're sitting on a rock so I can't if
that okay I did my best
waters going down okay good this is out
right here by I got you I'm sorry to try
to find a thing to help I'm trying
that's very good
mark can you uh fix some [ __ ] please I
will fix your mouth you might have to go
make a screwdriver I think there were
two last time oh one of the crew members
might have it though I think I had to
grab a screwdriver oh man temp low
output low why are you oh we have no
power to craft a screwdriver why don't
we have power I don't know I don't
understand the reactor keeping up with
stuff I don't understand I don't know
what is the what is the engine or was
the hello output low right now what is
the helm at is the helm on oh my god
worried 100% thrust that's why wait wait
it's not I was not 100% thrusting on
wait get to the helm oh my god oh my god
fire fire fire oh oh okay oh god the
helm is okay that was not what we were
going at before my god I was not on
master pilot I were you were a great
pilot puppy who are the best bottom okay
all right chillin chillin everything's
nominal on the reactor I'm putting my
suit back in yeah I'm gonna go take the
suit off so I can move around [ __ ]
despite my best attempts not to what are
the but what's the situation with the
ballasts ballast airlock airlocks full
alright I got that I got that alright
got a corpse is the airlock draining yes
okay I got that everything appears to be
draining but we're still not going up do
you have the ship going in an upward
direction
yeah these can be quite slow don't don't
over critter it if you're looking at the
gun turrets can you guys see the bottom
I am NOT I'm making sure everything up
here is behaving and okay we're going up
we're starting move up that one okay
good job hey let's get the swarm guys
let's do this
I don't
that was my fault whatever went wrong
there I think it absolutely very
temporarily increased thrust in order to
try to dodge walls
I've got internal damage in my head I've
got damaged in my I've got internal
heart damage and burn just so you know I
hope you guys are all ready to rock cuz
we're 300 meters away from the s'more
why I'm gonna bring one of these down
did I just use this okay I just said I'm
gonna set all the spare coil gun ammo by
the coil guns I guess what am i dying
what am i dying what I put in a bow to
cut my head and now I'm dying what what
it said I needed antibiotic and now I'm
dying to take an antibiotic I did I
think I overdose I think I'm gonna die
I'm gonna die what I hope knocks were
crushing the swarm I don't know what
happened
are you dead no I'm I'm alive but my
interface has gotten strange I'm gonna
just take some morphine yeah check for
90 meters which way which way okay there
we go I'm the right better now
always thinking why this go up are you
using the engines a lot because holy
[ __ ] this is a lot of power I had I had
to bump the thrusters up for a second to
dodge the bottom here cuz wasn't
responding hey your helm increased hey
good job big guy Thanks get him bud top
right all the swarms here whoa I can't
see it yet they swam to us they're on
the front of the ship
top of the ship on that ship what what
but what we're surrounded by swarms what
you're telling me that this swarm is a
swarm oh yes I killed some [ __ ] Oh
with [ __ ] more Gunners we might need
more Gunners I need to get my suit on
metal that's interesting they feed on
each other
ballast one which one's ballast one
front by the helm by the helm okay
coming in there's a swarm on the front
of the ship there's another one person
there's no air in this suit I need to
take it off fine I can't really shoot
straight up like on the edges of the
ship where I can't reach we got to get
out there and shoot him open the guns so
the guns are open I don't even know what
you mean
no open the gun room the armory it's
open its open its open it is not open
it's been open every time I've gone up
there because you have a key card to it
thank you no you opened it for me it was
it was open when I got there coz of the
shadows indicate whether it's open or no
God I'm standing at the door
unable to open it meaning it's not open
we're approaching straight above us oh I
need a cloak I'm gonna go out there and
I'm gonna shoot them and if I got one on
us I'm going out there and I'm gonna
shoot them here I go
good bye everybody bye Bart I can't see
the ones that I okay okay where is this
thing what are we talking about here top
right of the ship I see one on us top
right meters away top right top right
okay you big whiney bow are we falling
oh my god I think so oh my god Oh
airlock airlocks full come in come
falling too quickly why are we falling
hang on I need I need
preparin just do it okay okay sweet
freakin Jesus please please Godin all
right I'm going out again
so we're falling so fast yeah mate
where's the water we're slow no way
we're not we're not falling you're going
up wait don't go up without bag all
right told auto pilot to maintain
position here is this thing [ __ ] body
slam Green now we should be drained now
there is still a swarm on our ship I'm
trying to get to the ship
are you moving please have auto pilot
maintain position that's not happening
now but is it maintaining position I
think because it's a tear log over
control and just manually not move I'm
trying to manually not move you I wish
the autopilot hope somebody better than
my manual dude I am in the middle of the
ocean breach should be fixed that we
should be waterless wait you I with my
last breath I curse you wait god damn
guns right side going I'm killing
freaking everything just I know I don't
know where Mark went I hate you so much
I am dead
mark you okay yeah ma'am good yeah
were you at we're coming for you I'm
sure it's good top right how I don't see
him how where how they're sinking again
for some reason okay I'm gonna see how
far what the hell you guys are on the
bottom of the ocean again tell me again
I don't see those things over here you
see our deaf and you see what the sonar
is showing yeah we're at the bottom of
the ocean guys you I was swimming
upwards think cuz you went up and I'm
like oh you went up where are you good
job my first time being captain I was
also just captain for the first time
ever swarm swarm we're hitting one one
okay yeah oh god one one yeah one you
know I don't know how many came to meet
in the abyss for if you just go straight
up if you'll find my body if you go
straight up 42 meters we're between one
and two o'clock there are two that are I
think munching on a little piece of me
[Laughter]
you know you can stop holding left-click
and it won't move I'm trying to adjust
this to keep this thing and shooting
range for you I can't I'm not shooting
anything I can't see anything
30 meters straight up straight up
straight up go straight up yeah okay
where's one oh yeah
I marked it now but we did it got guys
crazy can you at least bring my body
back so my family
very alright pretty much accomplished
buddy good work all right thank you this
is going to be a rough you are a legend
again we're going down for God's I'm
glad I'm just really thrilled that you
guys are gonna die
now we're gonna be fine
Wow Gerald's really doing on oh wow
that's not good huh it's fine it's fine
I'm just gonna stand here with a fire
extinguisher and put it out repeatedly I
put two fuel rods in so we got extra
juice yeah that's never a good idea
we I okay you're just scraping along the
bottom of the ocean a little bit but
yeah okay well we're gonna go up
eventually it's fine we have we have
nominal power or we're not going up no
we're moving to the right but not up
you're going a little up do we have
water anywhere I don't understand not
that I see know where you are going are
the ballasts working I guess wait oh
[ __ ] over are things offline up here oh
we're starting to move up a little bit
now yeah wait it's house way let's not
have patience it's how you know how
acceleration and velocity are different
things yeah but I had it up and we were
scraping the bottom for five minutes man
what's offline Wade nothing up here is
offline what's the whole section
it just says offline because it's not
using the battery right now it doesn't
need to use the battery time are you
guys gonna come get my body insufficient
power right now something is not fine
well I'm going back to engineer well for
some reason I was dragged away from
engineering you should have some German
[ __ ] Danko he's trying to be positive
man why is it like I'm like trying to
belittle you as hard as you can you it
rolls off you but Jones like we can do
this and you're like King Jerry goes to
your [ __ ] I'm not used to your
[ __ ] we're down to the fuel rod in
the engine and
the extra one extra okay we're only 888
meters away but I don't know that we're
going up Martel bonhomie
no no I'm wet you left me way behind I'm
way by dropping six kilometers an hour
now we are but I'm telling you we
weren't 26 kilometers an hour what I was
violating I was keeping our velocities
under 10 in all directions where am i
way Pat you're way off to the [ __ ]
left no dude um I'm coming for you oh
are you in like a respawn thing are you
aware that you wait chopped-up up to the
left bun bun bun yep I think that's
where Mark is some supplies for us why
we have supplies for you screw you I'm
sinking again
are you I wait I'm like a hundred
percent sure that it's you how do I
steer this thing how do I actually make
a ship go so you guys see it nevermind I
see it I got I click and drag the arrow
and then it moves yeah well yeah I'm
coming for you big guy I'll cover for
you
humpy back II cover for you my nominal
nominal no I'm anal ok I'm coming in I'm
gonna dock with you guys so don't get to
the end when you sort of maintain
position we're moving mark I know you're
moving I'm aware of this I'm trying to
find you how far are you mark closer I
shoot you what I'm just curious I'm just
curious if that's pot if that's a thing
I knew you'd want I'm not saying that
I'm not saying that I would I'm not
saying that I would want to I'm just
we're uh musing out loud oh here comes
bunny yep okay I see you here I come
bunny up I'm happens if I do this I'm
gonna line up the doc no I mean maybe
wait what no what come doc I'm coming
I've got issues in the engine room well
it flashed red I'll check it out man
this docking thing's real stressful
yeah dakis [ __ ] nuts I'm running out
of power don't do that what and will
will talk to you or something um I ran
out of thousand bucks I'll [ __ ] no well
you can always hop out of the ship and
just swim back in right like that always
works out right all right I don't know
what what where's the engine
Mark Waid mark wait what what what blam
into us at relatively high of a loss to
say us Tim what do you mean trust me I
ran out of power
I don't treat oh I could see you bud
look at that
oh don't get squished how do I go this
George considered by thank you do you
have to close the airlock to your right
maybe look if you go in there and then
close that and then open the top what is
this pump no I don't want them custom oh
wait move slightly left he's drifting
away from us I'm just gonna force this
bad boy
oh not down but but you're I shouldn't
have told you to move I've got very
slightly going up I'm forcing this
current accelerating away from I'm
forcing this away I'm speeding it up
slightly responsibly what why can't I
open this thing why can't I open this
thing hey Bunyip we're accelerating
toward you why can I not open this thing
we're gonna die in the rescue submarine
I'm trying to force the door open with a
crowbar I can't I can't [ __ ] open it
what is happening docking mode you
literally it happens automatically if
you can get up
yeah wait actually Marc just chill and
wait you try and talk on to Marga then
that will say oh my god the other two
guys are dead
oh no shoot around the bots no they're
not around I can't get the thing open
I can't just ward oh [ __ ] a deathtrap
wait doc with him how oh I got it open
okay I got it over me what did you just
do Oh Oh do we have water Wade anything
thanks so much why were you laughing I'm
in the middle of the ocean again you
were laughing so you couldn't use your
eyes Wade just you have like three
things on your screen just look at them
Wade is the ship moving no is the ship
on the ground yeah
did you go straight down from where you
were
no it's straight down okay because I am
swimming again okay okay I am running
out of air we aren't moving cuz
ballistae k is a whole bridge I have to
go in through the bottom remember this
weight is the bottom axis okay I turned
off the we're not going anywhere that's
fine I just I'm gonna get to you first
do you see where am i how close am I
your I see your light meters Cassie
you're light ah you have quite a few
problems up here I'm gonna do you a
service and I'm gonna well it is shut
wait give me information what's
happening everything so a command room I
just flashed red once Bala think B just
flashed red guys like broke guys I need
you to come downstairs and open this
hatch I'm coming I'm coming I'm coming
since we're gonna rescue mark
and then all will be forgiven ties you
got like 10 seconds I'm right here
how do I open this come here why can't I
open it guys guys I can't mark what you
do why can't I open this just the ship I
power
oh wait wait I know I know okay mark
come here buddy coming
what do you mean that Mike coming it's
not open wait horse it I'm bobbing bub
bub I'm literally how do I open it it's
not opening poop
I jump I can't man I can't do anything
Bob it's cold puff what Papa don't die
mark I don't want to die off mark I cope
with the dog the dog i straight-up can't
open it please please go if I press this
button nothing happens please
[Music]
are you doing much literally wouldn't it
literally bangs at me I don't know what
it wanted I think everyone did a really
good job you have a good time Marc yeah
yeah you know a lot of fun I seriously
can't open this door I don't understand
I think it was just because there was no
power like a junction box didn't let
there was power though maybe not heard
of the junction box that went to that
button and I think that's one of the
situations where you would rewire
something to give four virginal power
Jesus flying on I'm just gonna end this
bad boy hey wait why are you hitting the
ground again my arrows in the up
position man I don't know did you drain
the power it's a real fine balance you
killed it
I'm trying not being very successful
about it
Oh God wave your back Wade you're
backing the ship up to run over my
corpse aren't you let me see if I can
let me see if I can end this misery real
quick here
that could find like a reactor for the
sub I think it just had batteries yeah
yeah wait I was I was there hard the
door open what that I was trying to pry
the door open from the outside it didn't
work commander why can't I kill us we're
still gonna kill it ourselves well
that's not what we want to do somebody
goodnight for good old Jerry I'm Way
ahead of you well he took the grenades
well he's an underwater scooter that
would have been good for mark yeah oh
hey Bob wait it wasn't if you you know
the funny thing is very concerning Wade
that you were just laughing when I was
drowning and that's very concerning
[Laughter]
[Music]